look who's here what are you doing here
oh you're kidding right by the way
there's always welcome of course this
moment is not all surprises are nice
Ross is here the legend we had no idea
no I'm coming now I album release date
no I had no idea who'd you talk to
books this room its role it was it
Roland give me a process of elimination
so I'll say say who was it Scott
Greenstein never um was it to Howard
Stern no Rolen Campos close okay how
about we go around the room Troy did you
know rich was coming in today I did you
do how did you find out he said it to
somebody in the booth for the Christmas
show he said he was coming in or did he
say I could come in I'm not sure of his
exact wording I didn't know that he said
this week I didn't know it was this day
but he said ah yeah oh you didn't know
he was coming in the meeting when you
sat down today you weren't like Oh
riches come I believe he said next week
right okay Travis did you know rich was
coming in today no again this is news to
you yep wait is our last the number-one
saboteur of the show
Rob did you know handsome Rob that rich
Voss was coming in today don't half jog
like that around the room we are going
to process I did not know either I did
not know I bet you're rolling knew what
is going on and he know you were coming
and just didn't tell us he forgot yeah
he's busy you know he's [ __ ] 14 shows
right I mean he's a talent book yes the
job yeah that'd be like if Jim and I
were like yeah we're busy we host a
radio show in the morning it's a good
notion five of them right in hosting one
but you know you gotta do your being
codependent and defending someone who
made her yours call not be in the snitch
you are a snitch and you always sounds
terrible I know I woke up with a sore
throat for the hotel
no I'm not sick you're a sore throat
like that qualifies you being sick
no maybe guys come with champagne hey
can you give me a coffee with a milk in
the Splenda open a fresh container milk
yeah yes today we have Rob Bartlett
coming in later get out of here yeah who
else that's it just Rob - we're happy
you're here which didn't know you were
here if somebody had said would you like
rich on Tuesday we would have said sure
that's that works I'd be perfect but
it's just when a legend walks in the
studio and it's a surprise to ask Jim
and I go huh yeah it's so crazy on your
album release date when I saw Hamilton
coming out on iTunes today that I
wouldn't be in here
we didn't why the day was coming out
honestly I didn't know that today was
your album release date but if I found
out today was your album release date I
would have said why didn't our friend
rich come by to tell the world that his
new album
when I saw Hamilton right he's out I'm
not Ryan what what I saw I mean so
inside rich I did just get word that
your album comes out tomorrow not today
Oh give it a day is he is Richard
awesome I don't think and we weren't
even told you be coming tomorrow wasn't
like we had to know it says on iTunes
yeah expected today I know pre-sales are
going but pre-sales has not released if
it's released it would just be sales but
look at go to iTunes it shows okay I'm
being informed it says tomorrow where'd
you tape it at brokerage either way were
promoters of course go and preorder it
today I just think it's funny
yeah no it's coming no I
if that's true I haven't seen the I to
know my manager said it comes out today
okay these two a be 18th here on the
wrong day let me look up
I got iTunes on my phone I could I could
tell you right now should we find out
Jim yeah you're very curious very ok let
me search for Voss and Hamilton because
the name of the album is one Iceland is
when I saw Hamilton let's give it a
search ski and it is available for
pre-order oh that's really only $4.99
every 399 pre-order it is expected to
come out December 18th tomorrow that's
fine rips of course it's fine but it's
not fine to come in and announce that
you're here I'm really not come up
tomorrow so my CD right right who would
have thought how the opening track is
about rich eating a vagina says I can't
do this one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the SiriusXM app
[Music]